información contradictoria en el campo
de batalla ucraniano
no hay soldados ucranianos en backmud
porque dejamos de tomar prisioneros hay
una gran cantidad de cadáveres de
soldados ucranianos ante el anuncio del
jefe del grupo paramilitar Wagner y
edgeniego sobre la toma de la ciudad de
bakmuth
Moscú respaldó la noticia el presidente
ruso Vladimir Putin felicitó a sus
tropas por la conquista de artiomos como
también se le denomina a la urbe en
Rusia el jefe de estado felicito a los
destacamentos de Wagner así como a todos
los militares de las unidades de las
fuerzas armadas de la federación de
Rusia que les brindaron el apoyo
necesario y la cobertura de flancos por
la culminación de la operación para
liberar artro mosc por su parte el
presidente de Ucrania fue aladimir
selensky fue ambiguo en sus respuestas
sobre bahamut desde Hiroshima señaló
primero en rueda de prensa que no creía
que la ciudad estaba bajo control
ucraniano luego rectificó su postura
refiriéndose a la situación de su
ejército
hoy ellos cumplen una tarea muy
importante están en bakmuth hoy donde
Exactamente no les voy a decir pero esto
significa que no ha sido conquistada por
la federación de Rusia No puede haber
otra interpretación
sus palabras Fueron secundadas por uno
de los portavoces de sus fuerzas armadas
nuestras unidades allí controlan un par
de edificios y tienen construcciones
fortificadas en la parte suroeste de la
ciudad
protagonizado los combates más
sangrientos en los últimos 10 meses de
guerra la ciudad es considerada
estratégica por el kremlin su control le
facilitaría El Avance hacia otras
localidades del Oeste de daniesk